each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
this is my great pleasure to introduce a
ready Vijay Vijay recently graduated
from Harvard University where he was
co-advised by Mike Smith and David
Brooks and he will be joining AMD
research labs soon and I sure win so
today he's gonna talk about software
assisted Hardware reliability so thanks
Aaron so some of this work that I'm
actually gonna be talking about as work
that I've actually finished up as part
of my thesis and I mean this is just one
when you work that I've looked at but
I'm not really gonna go into too much
depth because I'm going to talk about
processor reliability issues and
specifically one one particular thing
but what I'm trying to try and do is not
just get a nail down into one specific
paper I think I'm just gonna try and
stem things from the way it stands in
terms of the design variability issues
we're seeing sort of building of the
architecture piece and how software
actually becomes an integral piece in
the long run and so it's it's really
trying to put a vision together I mean a
lot of the papers are out there but it's
sort of trying to pitch whatever it is
that I've been pushing forward so just
to give you a brief introduction about
you know the kind of work that I've been
doing it's really I would consider
myself a software guy for the most part
what I've done is working binary
translators for those of you are in the
architecture community you would know
about pin which is one of the things I'd
worked on quite a bit
all through my masters and then I'd I
was basically looking for how do you
actually use software intelligently to
mitigate some of the hardware problems
so when I went over to Harvard I started
looking at architecture problems and you
know from architecture there are a
couple of circuit level issues that were
coming up basically in terms of
reliability and I started fusing the
fuse and the three things together in my
head and I kind of felt like there was a
new venue to you know a new venue for
research that's sort of emerging which
is what we'll talk about today so the
crux of the work is gonna be about
variations right so typically what we're
seeing is that you know transistor sizes
a shrinking now that's a great thing
because now for the same area you're
able to get a lot more compute density
but the problem is is you make these
transistor sizes so much smaller they're
becoming very susceptible to variations
now variations can be the static or
dynamic
static side it means that one transistor
has inherently different properties from
its neighboring transistor right on the
dynamic side and that sorry and that
basically comes out of process issues
right when you're fabricating there's a
design time challenges so the
fabrication and manufacturing time
challenges on the dynamic side dynamic
meaning it is sort of when the processor
is actually running on the static sided
gene and this is what you have you have
this kind of chip and that's got some
kind of variability within it on the
dynamic side you know the activity of
the program pretty much you know leads
to different amount of different hot
spots in the chip as we're saying on
this heat map or you can also end up
with voltage fluctuations within the
chip and that actually is going to
become a major problem in the future
most once the work that's out there
right now it sort of looks at the static
side the process variation level side of
things and there's been a fair amount of
work in the temperature or the dynamic
temperature side of things but voltage
variation is still not very well
understood in the space yet and that's
sort of really what I'm gonna peel off
into so that's gonna be the focus I'm
gonna start a real basic because it's
not really well known out there so I'm
going to talk about why voltage within
the microprocessor actually fluctuates
in a way that we don't want it to
fluctuate and why is that gonna become a
problem this gives a bit of the prior
work in the space and why some of those
existing challenge is not gonna scale
into the future and what we need to do
about it
and how the end of the day software
actually ends up becoming a very
critical piece in fact I'm gonna pitch
this entire architectural reliability
problem as a software optimization
problem do you know to the compiler
space and why the software will actually
be able to mitigate it much more
effectively than the hardware is going
to be able to do it so voltage noise
that's typically what we call this
problem voltage noise or voltage
fluctuation and one of the points of
warrant emphasized was that those
variations end up translating to some
kind of delay in the circuit and that
delays you know it's gonna impact the
performance of your chip right and
voltage especially is a big problem
because it impacts frequency and you
know the power efficient so you have the
cores and those are things will peel
into and they come in a couple of slides
but why does voltage within the
microprocessor
actually fluctuate well you understand
that or what I'm showing you here is the
current trace for a GCC you're running
an awesome later and we're
seeing that the current is fluctuating
inside the processor because while the
workloads doing different things over
you know the course of several hundreds
of cycles that we're looking at here now
the voltage and response is actually
fluctuating as well not typically you
want the voltage to be sitting around at
the nominal voltage right you want it to
be sitting idle at that point but it's
not and that's because there's
parasitics involved in the power
delivery network going from your power
supply like your battery source all the
way down to the actual execution units
and the PASOK's are what are causing the
voltage to fluctuate now in order to
make sure the processor is always going
to work correctly right we have to you
have to understand how much a swing
we're gonna dynamically see in here now
while PASOK's are one reason that the
voltage will fluctuate now you know
today's microprocessor is used clock
gating for instance there's a way of
saving power dynamically shutting off
you know parts of the processor based on
the usage now from a power perspective
that's great but again that's gonna
cause the voltage to swing because
whenever you see a sudden shift in
current the Pasig effectively caused the
voltage to swing much right yeah so I
was saying that that you want the
nominal voltage to be just you want the
voltage should be sitting around in the
nominal but it's not and that's because
of the parasitics and you need to
understand how much of a swing you see
in order to make sure that the circuit
work works correctly because of the
voltage falls below a certain operating
margin or a certain threshold value well
then you can end up with a slow circuit
right slower than what you have actually
designed or you're expecting it to
operate at at that point you can end up
with timing violations in the circuit
and then you end up with incorrect
results if it goes up too high then you
can potentially impact the the behavior
the trend you know you can impact the
characteristics of the transistor in the
end of damaging the transistor itself
and so you have you know a lifetime
issue and through the throughout the
rest of the talk I'm just gonna focus on
voltage emergencies or I'm gonna call
these things these points where you can
potentially run into these in correct
execution spots as voltage emergencies
and a morning only talking about the
correctness issue I'm not going to talk
about the life time issue because
correctness is fundamental to operation
and that has grave implicate and it has
grave implications on the frequency and
power efficiency of the processor
so the way we typically handle this
today industry-wide right the practice
is what you do is you try to determine
what is the absolute worst case wilted
swing you would see inside the processor
while it's actually running and the only
way to sort of determine that is to
actually write viruses that cause that
you really understand how much these are
very micro code kind of viruses that
where you try to understand how to
activate the functional blocks in a
certain way so they get these rapid
swings and current right and that
translates to voltage swings and that's
what they do and here I'm actually
showing you a snapshot of what I've
written for the Core 2 Duo processor and
you can see the voltage swings by a
large amount these are actually measured
results and that's effectively what they
do based on that large swing you can
determine how much of you know how much
of a guard ban or how much voltage swing
you can actually tolerate and then you
call this upper and lower market and
then you determine where you're gonna
set your nominal and then you run your
real program and what you see is that
the activity the real program is well
within those extremes so you're
guaranteed correctness
okay so margins get you that correctness
but the problem is that the way you
allocate these bands of this room for
guaranteeing correctness has severe
penalties it's like a static it's a
static penalty end up paying up front
for instance this for instance if your
nominal voltage is 1 volt right the IBM
power 6 designers for instance found
that any given point their voltage might
be able to drop all the way down to 0.8
volts just based on the activity inside
the chip what that effectively means is
that you have to make sure that although
you're only you're powering your
circuits with one volt the effect of
operating speed is set by point april's
because that you know that determines
the frequency and so naturally you're
losing some amount of peak operational
speed in the circuit and that's what I'm
trying to study here for the 45
nanometer design space where your
nominal set at 1 volt and what we're
seeing is that that translates toward 24
percent loss in clock frequency
immediately right now as you're going
into future nodes and if I believe ITRs
projections right what says that you're
gonna get about a you know you're going
to get some amount of voltage drop
slightly
but very minimal threshold voltage
scaling then that's gonna end up with
slower circuits as you're going in the
future that means that your peak
operational frequency for a given margin
for instance the way the power designers
power six designers are using for the
exact same margin what you end up seeing
is that the peak frequency starts
dropping pretty quickly now we might not
necessarily be focused completely on the
peak frequency you know in just in terms
of clock frequency improvements but
that's important because at the end of
the day you know it sort of determines
how much work you're gonna get done over
a period of time right so the frequency
is an important component here so the
only way to actually maintain frequency
from one generation to another for
instance is you have to enable tighter
margins but I just said that the whole
reason you have these guard bands or
margins is because you're trying to make
sure your circuits always operating
correctly and if you enable tighter
margins to sustain your frequency in the
future future processor and processor
generations then you end up with a very
high chance of getting incorrect
execution right and really you don't
have a choice I mean this is the
direction we will have to go because one
of the big ones is the margins also
impact energy efficiency or like you
know the amount of power your circuits
your processors burning for instance we
know when we look at the 20% margin that
I was talking about
imagine if you could lower you know your
nominal down to a much closer tighter
guard band right you can operate your
circuit at 0.8 3 volts and you're still
maintaining that same efficiency then
that translates to a 31% reduction in
your power and it's huge because this is
you know a chip wide effect it's not
sort of being optimized for a specific
workload or something this is just your
basic chip operation so it has you know
both frequency and and energy efficiency
issues and another thing that it
actually impacts is the cost of the chip
itself right with something which we
typically don't think about but when I
was talking to in tile guys they're very
concerned about the amount of
capacitance they would have to put on so
basically in order to tolerate voltage
swings so it's kind of hard to see here
but what they do is they put a lot of
capacitance in order to prevent these
large swings from happening it helps
them dampen the effect
and that's what I'm showing you here
this is a land side you know the back of
a processor you know the package and
there's a lot of capacitors here and as
I'm saying that the swings are going to
be getting larger basically voltage
noise becomes a bigger problem in the
future then you're gonna have to pack a
lot more capacitance which means you
know you're gonna happen less more on
the chip and then and if you don't if
you don't if you don't have the package
capacitance which is basically what I'm
showing you here right what I've done is
I've peeled a cap in the package caps
off you can literally pop them off
carefully you got to be careful you
don't shock the shot the chip but you
can see that if you if the package caps
reduce then you can see that the swing
ends up increasing a decent amount and I
will actually be using that as a way of
projecting in the future nodes in a bit
but there's a cost issue here as well so
far I was talking about you know
industry sort of designing for that
extreme worst-case point you know
because you're writing this power wires
that is that occurs that almost never
occur right in a real program that's
what you'd see and then you operate the
the average case time you know your
average case behavior is based on this
extreme design point instead why not
sort of you know really figure out what
the average behavior of the chip is and
then operate it accordingly don't set
those worst-case margins really just
sort of set more aggressive conditions
and what I'm showing you here at chip
measurement results and voltage samples
so zero percent means it's the nominal
voltage and each sample basically is how
much deviation you see in the in the
voltage going up or like below the the
nominal voltage and what I'm saying here
is that in the real production chip what
you see is that the swing is only about
three percent so it's a very very small
amount of voltage swing you see but
instead you know we go out and we put in
these large guard bands that where the
process very rarely stressed you in fact
it's it's it's a good thing that they're
doing it because that measurement
results do show that you do see these
very large swings inside the chip and it
does go as far as 12% and on the Core 2
Duo
we actually determined that the margin
that they install guys actually put in
was 14% so it does make
you know practical sense that they have
these large bands because that's what's
getting you that correctness at all
times but for the most part you know the
swing is only between 2 to 3% so instead
you want to typically operate under
these situations yeah under all these
situations at least I guess from which
you see on right there
is that they're sort of a constant
competitions
yeah if you have a more realistic
operating system scenario then you have
some bursts of activity which are then
called by versus of inactivity which
sounds an awful lot more like how I
would think of power virus would be
written so do you have a sense of that
in a real sort of operates as an
environment where the swing is actually
a lot more than this so these are
actually measured results on a chip
where you're actually wanting it with
the OS running and everything you have a
sort of a constant computation as
opposed to something an intermediate
computation like put the decoding a
video frame that comes every and times
the second like that the time skills
were talking about is extremely small I
mean it seems like the kind of
competition you're talking about is in
millisecond range but here the swings if
the current happens to drop dramatically
within a few seconds within a few cycles
that's the kind of granularity that
we're talking about a few cycles like
what's the what's the time constant of
your sort of worst case power miners
and what do you oscillate at to make it
have the worst possible how you
typically you'd want to oscillate it
around 100 to 200 megahertz the ships on
the current because that's when
basically you would see this in almost
every IBM paper intel paper it's where
the characteristics sit and that is the
point where you get the worst case and
so you can effectively I mean the virus
I'd written you know you can actually
figure out whether your codes actually
oscillating at that point by
constructing FFF keys and then you'd be
able to see it which was not really a
power virus was rugged yet easy virus
yeah okay so yeah okay sorry I could
little bit
yeah power virus it's quite different
from the di/dt virus but yeah yeah so
what I'm trying to argue for is that if
you if you look in a lot of the
production runs that we're seeing like
over several you know thousands of runs
most of the most of the data samples are
pretty much sitting within three to four
percent range so you don't really want
to optimize based on the 12% very
infrequent case that we're seeing you
want to design it for the typical case
typical case point because then you can
get a lot of you know frequency or power
power improvements and there's been a
little bit of work in the research space
sort of looking at you know what can we
do I mean do we really have to design
for it and people have been saying maybe
we don't need those extreme cases and
I'm gonna argue a little bit against you
know some of the challenges we're seeing
that if you're go and try to implement
it basically the notion is we want to
design for the typical case and which
means that if we have some amount of
voltage string you enable a tighter
margin right you want to run it closer
but then you you can end up with the
risk of getting incorrect execution when
the voltage dips below so the typical
solution has been all we're gonna build
sensors and spread them across the chip
and you're gonna have some kind of
detection mechanism right that's
basically sampling and then trying to
figure out does the voltage get too
close to a certain point and if it does
that means there's a high chance that
the voltage is gonna go beyond the
correctness margin right and at that
point you want to throttle or basically
slow the processor down a little bit and
you can do this at very fine grained
levels by controlling the issue rate of
the machine or you know the way your
dispatch instructions out and by doing
that you'd be able to prevent the
voltage from actually dipping below
right and then you prevent the emergency
because all it takes is one glitch and
that's it you know if you're if you get
incorrect execution you got incorrect
execution it doesn't matter whether this
happens once or a million times
correctness right that's what we're
going after
and the way there it's duplicated
typically implemented is by monitoring
the current of voltage in the processor
and if you if you if you cross that
particular voltage setting then you call
a throttling machine the throttling the
throttling system however you choose to
implement it they're multiple flavors of
that and the biggest problem here is the
delay the the the time it takes to be
able to detect something and then
actually respond to it and I'll showing
in the next slide that the delay has to
be you know has to be extremely small
and the challenge is with the delay is
that you have you have to have all these
sensors scattered across the chip
because you could get a droop anywhere
across the entire chip and that's the
problem really because you have to
detect all of them and then figure out
whether you really getting the problem
so where you set the threshold of the
way you figure out if you're going to be
crossing the margin becomes very
critical typically if your margin let's
say is your you know your average or
your average case in your design margin
is 4% very tight you get you're trying
to get the efficiency then you want to
set that threshold point where you're
gonna try and protect the processor as
close as possible to that extreme point
now when you do it one of the problems
is there's they might not just be enough
time to detect and prevent the voltage
from dropping below right and so that's
what we're seeing here if there's if you
assume that the redline is a typical
case the you know what the way voltage
is actually would happen if you weren't
trying to protect the processor and the
blue line is the one where you actually
do take action to try and prevent the
problem if there's not enough time or
the voltage is gonna dip below and
you're gonna end up with an incorrect
execution and it turns out that if you
really want to be able to pull this off
in this particular configuration for
instance right the delay to be able to
detect and respond has to be no more
than one cycle because if you go beyond
one cycle of detecting and response time
then you end up with the large
or failures and like I was saying all it
takes is one mistake right that's the
problem
and so therefore designing it is
extremely difficult because the typical
delay times for censors tends to be
around like 20 cycles or so even in the
best case if you assume it's got to be
about 10 cycles and it's impossible from
our data the natural thing to do is to
push the thresholds up right the trigger
threshold that way you have some room to
actually prevent the problem when you do
that you can very safely prevent the
problem but you can end up with you know
false positives when you try to do this
in the hardware because you know there
might be a case where the voltage does
go beyond that triggering point and then
you try to prevent and you try to
prevent it obviously and then you
realize that you don't really have to do
that turns out that this kind of
configuration you end up with eighty
percent false positives and the
penalties are huge because you're
throttling unnecessarily are you slowing
the Machine gracefully so those two have
been like you know pretty much the
prominent way of looking at these things
right industry does do the worst case
design right now but as we scale into
the future that's nice not gonna work
because the swings are getting bigger as
you make the transition you pull on a
lot more current and then naturally as
the voltage decreases and the current
increases you know your swing ends up
becoming much larger and so you must
have a much bigger guard band so that's
not scaling and the threshold techniques
that people have been proposing well the
problem there is that you know the
detection circuits are just not there
you're not capable of doing it and what
I'm gonna pitch two words is that you
really need to be able to understand
what is causing the voltage whitson
processor to actually fluctuate and
that's very much dependent upon how
aggressive your processor is and how
aggressive the microarchitecture is and
then what are the characteristics of the
power delivery network itself and how
the program is actually behaving because
if the program tends to have a loop that
maybe does not actually resonate at that
frequency then you're not gonna get the
problem the emergency problem so it very
much depends on how the program behaves
as well and in this talk I'm actually
gonna try and take that combined
approach given that we know that that's
what
those interactions are the ones that
actually caused the problem I'm gonna go
the route of actually understanding by
looking at the voltage traces understand
how we can actually design a better
solution and what we found is that when
you actually look at those voltage
fluctuations inside the processor you
realize that it's actually recurring
basically meaning that there's a very
strong recurring pattern once you end up
with the problem we found that the
problem pattern tends to repeat over and
over and then it's pretty much based on
actually the reason that these swings
happen is because of sudden stalls
inside the processor because when the
processor suddenly stops then there's a
huge shift in the current okay and that
causes the voltage to swing by a huge
amount and the stalls tend to be a big
you know the events tend to clump
you know the micro architectural events
are pretty good indicator when you're
getting a stall and it's also the
program the code itself how the code is
actually running and so I'll walk you
through an example of that in the next
few slides just to put a context around
yeah so actually once you start into the
software piece and that's where the
hardware piece starts crumbling a bit
because we you know I start off saying
that you know we can build for a single
core I show how you can actually build
an intelligent hardware structure that
gets rid of the the way people have been
proposing you know you can actually
implement it and that'll solve the
problem in one core and I haven't
extended that into like the two core
systems that you know the basic multi
core system but that's what the software
becomes much more critical because
trying to trying to gather an assembly
data from multiple cores and very short
time skills is just next to impossible
right and trying to figure out the
interactions is even more difficult but
the software then you know by combining
that because we all because we have
understood how events across the
processor sort of cause voltage to swing
across multiple cores cause the voltage
to swing you can actually schedule the
code accordingly and by code meaning
multiple threads
so the way we do it has actually we
assume some feedback mechanism yeah I'll
get when I get to that point I'll
actually explain what kind of feedback
mechanism you need and what we actually
end up using so for most of the
measurements the way we do is just you
know because I've talked about some of
the data the way we do it is actually we
tap into the you know VCC and VSS pins
that are you know that you can actually
tap into from the at the back of the
motherboard and we use a differential
probe because these are very high
frequency measurements and capture that
on the scope where we are processing
things on that as the programs are
running doing execution and then analyze
it offline one vcss or we have one VCC
on one corner in a different VCC on the
other so the ones to the multi-core
system that I'm actually gonna be
talking about is all connected with the
same power same input line but the ones
I haven't looked at it's not zero
resistance lines now
so how bad of a difference if if what
end of the trip with one vote how bad
with the other end of GP it's not
necessarily that you know it's the same
equivalent that's the thing I think
that's the point you are making and so
what we what we are tapping into is you
know a basic keyhole view of what is
really going on inside the processor at
that point where we're actually
measuring the voltage so I'm not gonna
walk through the validation process you
know we have validated this thing and
made sure that our set up is actually
representative of what we expect to see
in terms of our our measurements given
some kind of test cases running on the
processor that actually makes sense they
have done the validation with the court
do dual results that Intel typically
provides the motherboard regulator
designers so that's all just when the
measurement characterization kind of you
know basic set up but this is the way we
actually sort of look into solutions in
the future
what we have is really in order to
really understand what is going inside
on inside the processor we use a
simulator and it's it's an x86 simulator
what we're what we do is we we rely on
watch to get the power model or the
current consumption which basically
tracks micro architectural activity
within the processor and that's watch
that generates current and then we feed
that into a power delivery model that we
have and that power delivery model
basically every cycle by cycles fits
odds you know what the voltage is and we
use that as our feedback mechanism into
into whatever solutions at the higher
level were interested in looking at and
this has been this is primarily on the
single core set up for the multi-core
I've just done it all on the real system
and so when I get to that point I will
be talking about that so my solution to
the whole thing is you know it's called
tolerance of Borden's elimination it's
the way it's the way I think we should
be going about this problem and this is
just on the voltage noise side but I
believe we can expand it the idea is
instead of always allowing sort of
completely preventing the voltage from
ever really dropping below the point the
idea is we allow the voltage to actually
dip below the margin right we're
allowing incorrect execution so
basically is an error
one circuit or airport ship and then
when we detect that the voltage has gone
below then we know that the computation
is incorrect and then we rely on a
recovery unit to roll the execution back
and install actually I actually be
talking to them on Friday and they do
have a prototype ship that actually does
the error recovery right now so it's you
know it's sort of coming together and
they're actually very much interested in
how you do the avoidance mechanisms this
wall because they're thinking about
putting these things in because you
cannot always rely on allowing errors to
happen it's just too costly basically I
feel a lot of them to happen ship
voltage drops below and there's no
longer reliable how can you rely at the
rollback is done correctly
because the rollback pretty much assumes
some money delay by the time you detect
it and you're keeping snapshots so that
the time when you take the snapshot
versus when you actually detect the
delay is all sort of you know you know a
per re and you're configuring it that
way but all that is done in the same
sort of logic yes so how do you have
that logic is functioning so that part
is like timing protected I think that's
what you're trying to get
so yeah so you basically allow errors to
happen and when you get an error you
correct the execution back but by
allowing errors to happen that's just
the first step right going in the future
what we ideally want to do is we want to
be able to predict these things and say
okay we want to get rid of the problem
altogether right we want to be able to
anticipate the fact that the voltage
will dip below and so I'll show you that
you can actually build an intelligent
predictor mechanism by understanding by
relying on tolerance you understand what
causes the problem then you can actually
build an intelligent predictor for that
problem and then you can then take that
and from what we learn you can actually
push it up even further to the software
level where the software can completely
eliminate the problem altogether by
restructuring the code or scheduling the
threads a bit differently on the
microprocessor so I'm going to talk
about tolerance first right because it
allows us to understand what is causing
the problem so for this I'm going to
walk you through a pretty complicated
series of animations which will sort of
explain what within the microprocessor
is actually causing the voltage to
really swing hard and when you actually
get a problem because by understanding
that then you can actually take
preventive actions so I'm showing you
the voltage trace for GCC over eight
hundred cycles itself and what we see is
that if we set a four percent margin you
end up with potentially incorrect
you know you can end up with voltage
emergencies right and at first it looks
like you know it's pretty random you
know it's just random fluctuations but
if we were to splice this up you would
see that there recurring patterns in the
noise ABC basically did recording phases
of voltage activity and what we found is
that because we're in the simulator were
able to easily stitch it back up to the
code level and what we find is that GCC
is actually initializing its register
set and this is doing the first part of
the code and it's all in the loop and
sort of makes sense that that's why
you're getting these recurring problems
or these recurring swings
these repeating patterns but what we
were specifically interested in is why
do we suddenly see these large swings
right at this point why not here versus
there and when we observe the activity
inside the processor what you find is
that pipeline flushes are going on or
the basically the microarchitecture
mispredicted a branch right and at that
point it has to drain the entire
pipeline out so it's a sudden stalling
activity and that causes the voltage to
swing but what's interesting is also
that only few of them view as those
southern pipeline stalls actually caused
an emergency like this one doesn't but
this one does right and so so that's
what we want to figure out sort of what
are those subtle differences and what is
so different about this branch
misprediction versus that branch
misprediction and when we related back
to the code we find that the hot spots
are a bit different so to here
corresponds to the basic block in the in
the control flow graph there we're
looking at the branch the branch that
controls the basic block the path
falling following basic block two and
five means the branch sure whether
you're going this route or whether
you're actually gonna take this loop
back edge Pat it's a back edge going
back you know it's a loop so for
instance we see that five whenever it
miss predicts we remember the machine
miss predicts on the branch five we
always get a problem right we always end
up with an emergency but in the case of
two that doesn't happen and to sort of
figure out what is so special about -
you know why - only causes a problem in
one situation versus you know in seed in
a doesn't cause a problem you have to
really understand what what code the
machine is actually executing and the
best heuristic for that is the issue
rate of the machine so we see that in a
and phase a where you don't have a
problem the issue rate is pretty jagged
right so that means you know there's a
lot of the both the the current is not
being consumed very aggressively there's
sort of an average smaller amount of
current but in B the processor is
consuming a large amount of current and
I say that the processor is consuming a
large amount current directly from the
issue graph because the issue logic
typically consumes is there is a brain
of that processor right so it consumes a
decent amount of power and so here
you're seeing already zoom in a bit here
you're seeing that when in B the
processor is issuing a lot of
instructions and really being aggressive
does
and it's doing exactly what you would
like it to do it is running a lot a lot
of instructions within a short amount of
time but when you get that branch
misprediction here at that point the
issue completely stops the Machine comes
to a sudden still and then that causes
the voltage actually to swing up very
quickly and then slightly pass a little
you know maybe about a couple of cycles
down the issue ramps up suddenly so
there's a complete stall and currently
current draw and then there's sudden
burst because there's a lot of ILP
sitting on on the correct path and
that's what's actually causing the other
but the sudden current draw is causing
the voltage to actually drop below
whereas here it's a bit different right
following that you know following this
point here you're able to see that the
issue is not that aggressive and those
subtle changes are effectively what you
know determine whether you have a
problem or not and relating it back to
the code what you see is in a where you
don't have a problem versus B where you
have a problem the path that the program
is actually taking are slightly
different processors perspective
if sudden drops an activity or problem
and the processor just compensating a
lot of busy work then obviously
container
so you can actually yeah if that couple
you're gonna end up dilating it but the
problem is you can't do that with every
single pipeline flush in fact if you do
that your ability if we think about it
as that being a heuristic to predicting
you know whether you will actually get
an emergency or not then it's really bad
it's about 8% or so you need to be able
to track the history that is actually
causing the problem not just oh did I
get a branch misprediction because the
branches are just one one point where
you get this problem if there's actually
cache misses TLB misses and in fact you
don't even need any you don't even need
to have specific micro architectural
events that cause problems the code
itself can be a problem it wouldn't
really know when to do it because yeah
sometimes there's actually no indication
because it's just the way the code is
resonating inside right and actually I
will get to the point where I'll show
you an example where a divided
instruction basically stalls the
processor in a way that it actually
causes this effect sorry but all those
cases the TLB cache misses and
the property of mentioning what those
all be visible through the issue great
isn't that where the processor can
realize how much I mean this they should
be correspond very tightly with the
current drop it tends to correspond
pretty easily yes you're saying just
monitor the issue rate I think we do
things yeah I monitor this sure even
make sure that issue rate doesn't change
too who drops too quickly the new feet
work and if it rises too quickly I think
that's that's exactly what I mean that's
a good idea or it fundamentally it's a
very simple and a good idea to do it but
the problem is being able to detect that
Delta in a very short amount of time
right because these increases and drops
are so sharp they're by the time you
detect and you actually respond to it
that's where the problem comes and
that's the soft threshold mechanism I
was talking about
hey you're effectively trying to detect
whether that's happening and that's
that's the big problem being able to
detect and respond just requires very
quick response time that we cannot
actually build linguist ignore before
active mechanism where I can simply if I
issued an instruction to cycle I have my
scheduler you know not so just simply
not prevent the issuing of more than and
plus K the next cycle where I can choose
K so that I don't actually ever have you
know ramp up at I see what you're saying
so it just completely just do it on base
on the entry way so that I'm just going
to make sure that I never ramp up a ramp
down importance
yeah I think I'm not too sure but I
think that was some oh okay wasn't for
the IDT but that's something I have not
actually looked at I'm really seen but
maybe yeah if you don't rely on any of
the detection mechanism and you just
look at the issue rate it might be
pretty attributable man because you
still have to choose that K the other is
still do it in a way that you guaranteed
that you know the current the current
fluctuations don't change my words yeah
yeah it's a really complex analysis yeah
I think that would also depend on sort
of what functional blocks are you
activating doing that set of
instructions right leadership that I
think would make it harder but the point
I was trying to build from this this
slide is that it's a mix of program and
micro architectural activity in the past
that actually lends to whether you know
you're gonna get an emergency or not and
that actually does the cases to wall
okay it's not just random swings or
something it's there's something
intelligent we can really do because we
can understand it at this level and so I
was saying you know we if we tolerate
the emergencies right you allow them to
happen and you build these recovery
mechanisms then you can actually just
use that I mean one idea is to just rely
on that and the problem with that is
that you have to implement very
fine-grained recovering mechanisms that
are pretty intrusive to the
microarchitecture I means you have to
make merry you know and when I was at in
town I was talking to these guys some
time back they were saying that making
any changes to traditional
microarchitecture structures in order to
enable very finely in recovery is a big
pain in the butt because yeah it takes a
lot of validation and testing that's a
big a real pain for them so just to show
you the kind of the recovery cost that
you typically would need to implement
ensuring you a heat map here of the
amount of performance improvement you
would get from using a very aggressive
margin right so the core 2 duo has a 14
percent margin and we're gonna set that
to a typical case so you know whatever
value we choose in here ideally you'd
want to be a lot of 4% all right and so
as you as you make that margin tighter
what you're seeing is the color becomes
more vibrant and the blue color here
means that you're getting a tremendous
amount of clock frequency improvement
right because you're able to run it
faster and that do some extreme would be
able to
later into program performance and if
you want to get this piece here well you
would start realizing that your recovery
mechanisms have to be around hundred
cycles or so and that's pretty intrusive
and something there has been some work
in from within our own group looking at
this stuff
right basically just purely designing
just the recovery mechanisms only and
razor for those of you familiar with the
architecture side I mean razor is where
this kind of notion all started off and
the problem is it is very intrusive and
you had to change you know yeah I don't
have to identify your critical paths and
all that and although it's from a
performance standpoint it's a great way
of doing things it's designing and
building it that's the problem and so
what I'm gonna be talking about is how
can we use some kind of coarser grained
recovery mechanism right which are sort
of coming out because the ability to
allow program execution to continue and
then take some kind of checkpoint State
is becoming very interesting for many
users for instance there's a lot of work
out there saying we could do debugging
this way in multi-threaded programs for
instance right you could track some of
the history and so the notion is is to
basically leverage some of the existing
recovery logic that people have been
pushing out as this general purpose
piece of hardware that you can use for
multiple reasons and then apply that to
mitigate you know to get the performance
improvement that we want and that's
ideally what I push for because if we
want to use the really if we want to get
this very good amount of improvement
then we'd have to be around ten cycle
recovery cost which is really I mean
that's almost even more fine-grain than
a branch misprediction cost and that's
what I'm gonna show so here what I'm
trying to show you here is that's the
kind of recovery cluster you'd want
right now
right that is for today's processor but
as you go into the future and then I'll
tell you how we are projecting but is it
going to the feature what you start
seeing is that the potential here you
have in terms of the recovery cost
quickly starts diminishing so use proc
25 this is typically projecting into
like about the 22 nanometer spacer cell
and that starts dropping and then as you
go even further and in the 1611 you
start seeing that even the recovery cost
really has to be extremely fine grain
and this is based
on the assumption that you know the
voltage will scale a little bit which is
what ITR is is expecting and the current
density is going to increase and the way
I've been doing it and the way I come to
the conclusion is we take an existing
chip and we measured the data and we
look at the recovery cost versus the
margin trade-off in order to project
into the future where we expect a
peak-to-peak voltage swing within the
processor to increase we artificially
fake that out and fortunately can't
really see it but what we do is we
reduce the number of capacitors packaged
capacitors and that artificially causes
the swing to increase and that an effect
that allows us to study what's gonna
happen at the end of the day and this is
just a vehicle the end of the day this
is what we're really interested in and
this is showing that as you end up
breaking caps off in the swinging
increases because of the larger number
because the average swing increases then
you end up with more recoveries that are
going on inside the processor and
because of that because of that increase
in recovery cost increase in frequency
of emergencies the recovery cost has to
become smaller because the penalty per
emergency needs to decrease dramatically
and that's effectively what's happening
and so we really need to understand you
know how to be design and mitigate the
problem and of course I wanted to show
you that the swing here the magnitude of
the swing as it is increasing when you
do when you start breaking capacitors
off but sorry about that
so by tolerating what I'm saying is that
we can understand we can understand what
is causing activity and because we're
not gonna be able to build as extremely
fine-grained recovery mechanisms we want
to be able to build lighter weight
schemes on top of it and that's what I'm
gonna talk very briefly about the
predictor which I call as the principle
for avoidance
the idea is you allow the emergency to
happen inside the processor right and
you detect that that's happened and you
can detect it using the typical sensors
I was talking about which might take
long a bit of a time to actually detect
it but that's completely fine because
we're not trying to proactively prevent
it and when you detect it you initiate
you check on recovery which rolls the
execution back to some previously known
state
and you know that state is correct and
you notify what we caused the emergency
predictor and the predictor then
basically takes a snapshot of some
activity that was happening because like
I was saying when you were doing
checkpoint recovery you're actually able
to track you know what is going on
inside the processor you maintain some
history you track that and then you can
actually predict using that activity
pattern you don't really have to wait
the next time around so that allows us
to basically prevent the emergencies and
so here I'm showing you what the
predictor would actually track in
Hardware so it's just some control flow
I'm showing you here but of course like
I said there might be other micro
architectural activity and you track
those patterns and you store them in
your table and these patterns actually
become very important for the software
piece because unless you know what
caused the problem you wouldn't really
know where to actually fix the problem
so that's why these signatures are very
critical for the software piece and so
what I'm trying to show here is how far
ahead does this do these patterns allow
you to you know predict and anticipate
the problem and that's what I call as
lead time if you order to get an
emergency here you know you ideally want
some amount of lead time so you can take
some preventive action and I'm showing
you that even if you go 16 cycles ahead
of time yet it's able to predict those
patterns that we were able to record
even 16 cycles we even with 16 cycles
amount of time you can actually predict
them very accurately up to 90% accuracy
which is huge and if you were to just
rely on that simple detection mechanism
then it's about sorry yeah so accuracy
is the way the way we look at it is what
fraction of okay we record how many
times the emergency happens and each
time we track we we compare whether the
predictor with whatever history it
looked at did it also expect an
emergency at that point so basically the
particular you might get some kind of
activity history pattern and you look at
that history pattern and you say or did
I get that emergency when I saw that
pattern
there's 10% false negatives 10% that you
missed 10% minimis how many extra ones
he thought you were going to
didn't necessarily
how many extra ones that so if I say so
if I made a predictor that said predict
every cycle that's a halt in your
emergency
this metric would have 100% accuracy
no you saw wood
because there's still some amount of
errand in the in the history history
that you court because you record in
history and well if the basic block is
huge for instance right and then you're
only tracking control flow
well that means sorry I think my
question is more and the best to your
measure of accuracy as to your I thought
the thing he said was that your sing the
note the percentage of emergencies which
you predicted would be an emergency yeah
false positives and false name you false
positives and false negatives so
actually that mergency is 100%
based on yeah so I did do it so this is
not based on actual run where the the
predictor is actually active as well and
when we do that actually they tends to
be this behavior where if you as you as
you're preventing some of the emergency
some of the feature nearby emergencies
go away so in fact it turns out that
only 1% of the emergencies actually we
miss the predictor would miss one this
is of course assuming that you've
already learned the pattern that's what
I'm saying so first you have to learn
the pattern right that's a compulsory
miss just like in a cache miss and once
you get that once you've figured out the
pattern that causes the problem then you
can use that to anticipate the future
the future occurrences and when we do
that we realized that 99.99 percent of
the time we were able to prevent the
problem that is in the actual run
because they actually throttle so one of
the things obviously it's very much like
a branch break right sorry
just like the unifying they justify was
being stressed out and these execution
units are not the same it's actually
it's instructional right because I look
at branches or it's it's not completely
instructional it's a bit of
instructional and micro architectural
events because I basically encode oh
this is a branch
it's a taken or not taken branch and
then I will also encode in whether you
got a l1 miss or l2 miss actually yeah I
was gonna get to that in the next slide
because we turns out they we just need
to track a small fraction so it's about
seven events or so because those are the
ones that really end up counting the
major stalls so because it's very much
similar to a branch predictor like
structure than what you see is as the
amount of information increases then
obviously you're tracking more history
and therefore your ability to actually
predict the problem you know increases
and where you track the information for
instance I think this is sort of what
you're asking where you're tracking and
what kind of events you're tracking
right what I'm showing you here is if in
this the first three basically assumed
the code path you're only tracking the
program path right and it shows that if
you capture the commit side which means
you're only looking at the true program
path you're not looking at speculation
effectively you're ignoring branch
mispredictions right then you only get
40% but when you go to the decode you
end up capturing some of the speculation
that the processor is doing so you're
effectively capturing the misprediction
implicitly then your accuracy improves
so branch is obviously a major thing and
as you throw in more events basically
TLB misses l1 and l2 effects then your
accuracy improves dramatically
so the signature sizes this is what I'm
talking about here so this is the number
of entries and I use three bit n
coatings for each of the entry
so like I was saying right at the
beginning you can either go you know if
you use aggressive margins you can
either get power reduction or you can
boost up the clock frequency here I'm
just going to talk about it from a
frequency perspective so in our system
we had a 40 and 14% in worst case group
typical just the way the Core 2 Duo
processor was experiencing and we chose
a 4% based on the aggressive setting you
know whatever the average case design
point seemed like and that translates to
a 17 point 5 percent increase in clock
frequency you would be able to get by
using aggressive margin and what we see
is that if you compare against an oracle
predictor scheme the oracle you know
because it still has to throttle once
for emergency right so it knows exactly
when the problem is gonna come and it's
gonna pay a little bit of penalty you
would see that compared to the 17.5% it
comes to about 15% which is very close
but you're still paying some performance
penalty and if you take the signature
predictor which is the one we have come
up with it comes very close to the
oracle and in fact that does it even
after it's relying on these very
expensive training mechanisms right
because it has to actually incur a
problem take that problem and then apply
it at run time so basically learn pay
the cost for learning and after that
it's a it has to be able to predict very
effectively to do this but there's
actually more room to push it even
further right and that's where the
software piece kind of comes in and i
have to talk a lot about the basic phone
you know I really had to lay the
foundation for how the software would
actually be able to do these things
because you have to understand what is
causing the voltage to swing and the
predictor is a very key piece of this
entire scheme because it captures that
it captures a record or the the history
patterns that are needed inside the
compiler to actually change the code
around
is that just a frequency increasing
achievers actually this is actually once
the speed-up once you're actually
wanting to program
so so from tolerating we can will now
figured out what is causing the problem
and now we can once and then you're able
to predict it accurately and the
prediction although it seems like a
hardware thing it's actually very
important for the software right because
it is a representation of the what is
the quality of the information you're
giving the software because the software
is gonna basically operate off of that
and so the software once it gets the
profile information from these Hardware
structures would actually be able to
change the code and that's what I'm
going to talk about in a single-core
system right and then when you go to the
multi-core system you can actually
schedule threads intelligently see I
should get rid of the problem altogether
so basically and never gonna have a
voltage emergency in effect and so when
you actually look at what we did was we
took the programs and we observed the
number of the locations where this
problem actually happens in terms of
program structure what we find is that
there very few places in the code where
you get these emergencies and they tend
to be hotspots and that's what I'm
showing you here across the three
different benchmark suites with oh I'm
training is the dynamic emergencies is
the number of emergencies you actually
incur during program execution and the
static locations if you were to relate
it back to the control flow graph of the
program you know how many places do you
actually end up with an emergency and
it's a very small fraction it's
basically just a few hundred
instructions or instruction hotspots
that cause the entire problem so it
actually motivates everything for the
software because it you know if this
problem is sort of scattered all across
the code and then then it's very hard
for the software to really be able to do
anything the software schemes work
really well when there's a repeating
pattern right because changing something
at one located in locations specifically
for a given problem is much more
effective so here just to make just
really explain you know we looked at
some of the control flow stuff control
flow graph stuff and just to sort of say
how the interaction between the micro
between the program control flow and the
events that the processor experiencing
can actually make a problem I'm showing
you benchmark sieve so what
is the coat you get an emergency out
here in this section of the control flow
graph and you get this because what
happens is the process ends up stalling
briefly at a certain point and that it
stalls when we get a divided instruction
because this divided instruction is a
long latency operation and effectively
until it's computation is in a process
the rest of the instructions cannot
actually be dispatched so and this is in
a loop and so what we see is that you
get a stall here that's that's what we
observe actually when we look at the set
of processor events here we were
observing we see that the long latency
thing divided happened when you get that
divided the issue rate of the machine
right suddenly comes to a complete
standstill and that's because there's a
dependency on that instruction right
because a machine cannot Pro cannot go
forward until you know that that
computation is finished and so the
current dropped drops dramatically but
when the computation finishes right you
see a sudden increase in the issue rate
as expected because now suddenly all all
the instructions are being executed the
following the dependent instructions and
then you see a that's why the current
increases the because the current
increase is steep and it's sudden you
see that the voltage actually drops
suddenly and what we effectively end up
doing is that we can actually change the
way the code is structured and sort of
dilate that sudden burst in activity and
then prevent the problem so it's
basically because of the sudden issue
rate you're getting that voltage drop
right and that's happening because
there's a lot of ILP and the way I'm
showing that is like let's say your
machine can typically issue two
instructions a cycle it's going great
right and each cycle it's able to
dispatch that number of instructions
then you know naturally there's a huge
issue rate and then the current is going
to be consistently high and the color
ciara represent instructions that are
effectively dependent that means they
cannot proceed until the previous
instruction completes what we want to do
is we basically want to stall the issue
rate out a little bit and by doing that
you know you're getting that averaged
effect and that prevents the problem and
so we effectively want to what
the Machine does add a given point and
you want to do
intelligently because you just cannot do
it all all over the place otherwise you
lose performance dramatically and by
chaining up dependent instructions
together you can actually end up slowing
the Machine just enough at the right
hotspot and B and we actually tried
doing this in a static static compiler
and the problem is when you change
something in one place the problem ends
up creeping up at another place so you
effectively have to kind of keep fixing
it on the fly that's what we have found
and that's what we actually end up doing
it's a dynamic feedback system so I'm
trying to show here is you know if you
have one instruction for instance a move
instruction if you could move that
instruction down and increase the read
after write dependence chain at the
right place then well of course the
compiler has to move instructions with
you know making sure you're still
preserving all the semantics correctly
if you can do that then what you see is
that you know so this is a before that
the one we had a problem in and this is
the after then what we see is that we
flat out the issue rate a little bit
right so we crippled the ILP of the
Machine and then that way you decrease
the amount of current draw just a little
bit effectively and that prevents the
voltage true
voltage drop decrease and it's a bit
tricky to do this in an out-of-order
machine because you have to worry about
the instruction scheduling window
because it's pretty big so a lot of
nifty tricks that we had to pull on it
do I get it right as a compiler has
specialized for every speed read of
every stepping of every processor I'm
sorry it seems that the compiler hasn't
been done differently for every speed
grade of every stepping of every
processor I think it's sort of
to be what do you mean by speed great
you might use you buy chips without
thinking gigahertz and 1.2 billion Hertz
or not and finally good you pay more
money for them and explained in your
face to work if it hurts ready right so
think we haven't actually seen it like
you know okay so we just took one chip
on which we are trying this out and I
think our the point at which were were
able to show is that below actually we
would actually be able to come up with
an algorithm that makes sense and so I
guess they cannot strongly make the
claim that all this would just work out
of the box because we're still looking
at how the Copts Amaya's ation has to be
built so that it is it's gonna work
completely independently off the
platform itself what we found basically
was that if you can if you can if you
can construct the chain so that it
matches the issue rate the issue width
of the machine and we found that it
typically works very well so it's a it's
a very simple heuristic that we found
but it seems to have a very tight
correlation with how effective this
scheme is the only problem is you have
to worry about how big the instruction
window is of the machine if it's really
big trying to create read after write
dependence chains is extremely hard
because you have to find those chains
all over the place another simple way is
to just throw in no op instructions or
something to dilate the time and so
that's what I'm trying to show here is
if you reschedule the code intelligently
right then you can reduce a large number
of emergencies and I'm showing you the
fraction of emergencies that remain
after just one optimization after just
one pass that we have named and if you
actually try to dilate the time you try
to lend them things out by injecting
instructions into the stream arbitrarily
just because we have a hot spot at some
point and the compiler says oh based on
the emergency signature pattern it looks
like the hot spot is here and I need to
fix that and you just start throwing in
instructions to basically the
ILP then that becomes a problem because
that can actually introduce unnecessary
stalls and that's what we find that we
lose performance actually I mean so
naturally if you introduce no op
instructions you're gonna lose time
because you're doing a lot of
unnecessary work versus if you actually
reschedule the code intelligently then
you can actually get better performance
at the end of the day right but the
point I'm trying to make here is
when we reschedule we're not getting
performance improvements because we
changed the code a lot but it's just
that the OP you can actually come up
with optimizations that are not
completely performance driven right you
just specifically optimizing the code
just for this problem yeah so you
actually construct pseudo-ops so you
have to look at the code and then
basically force it to actually do some
computation that's actually redundant
yeah so we do Sudan ops it's not really
no ops because you're right the thing
that's this gets killed out at their
dispatch piloting at the decoder after
it closed because so yes so we actually
looked at the compiler itself the
compiler itself does end up getting
emergencies when it's actually doing the
thing so the way we handle it is because
you're you have a tolerance mechanism at
the end of the day right so we make this
huge assumption that the baseline is
always there is always a corrective
mechanism at the hardware and so
whenever we get that fault we just take
the fault and we observe the penalty
loss inside the compiler
and the thing is that if your compiler
is good and if you if you can really
optimize it correctly then the number of
times you would have to call the
compiler would be very few right that's
that's the assumption if the
optimizations don't work and then you
keep calling the compiler then it
becomes redundant and so what we
actually end up doing the way the entire
system actually works is you propagate
stuff up to the software level but if
the software cannot fix it then that
emergency signature that the software
relies on is actually fed back into the
predictor mechanism because the hardware
because this is much more cheaper to
maintain the performance than relying on
completely tolerating you emergency
right
sorry ah yes of course then now as we go
into like the multi-core systems you
know so ah that was just on the single
course if you can optimize localize you
know you're basically perfect performing
very localized optimizations to get rid
of the problem but what happens in the
multi-core well then you have
interactions across another chip right
another core that can actually cause
problems on your own your core because
typically in a multi-core system a
certain number of cores for instance you
know two or four six cores can actually
be tethered to the same power supply so
what that means is if one core is
misbehaving in the end of penalizing
every other core because the group will
propagate down and IBM guys have
actually done the way they do it is it's
pretty crazy because they'll actually
send they'll create a droop on a one
core they actually absorb it traveling
down and they'll say that okay after X
number of nanoseconds then you will see
a you know and if they're the second
core happens to fire up right at that
time then you get a much bigger group so
they do these kind of very detailed
studies torna deal with them in the
multi-core system and as it's we're
starting expand into like many many more
of course this droop issue becomes more
significant because if anytime all the
cores happen to fire up draw a lot of
current then your the droop is gonna be
much bigger so that means your guard
bands have to increase substantially
larger when you end up compromising the
overall efficiency of the system itself
and so in order to mitigate that what I
was looking at was you know how does the
noise within the program actually change
over time and I'm showing you three
benchmarks from CPU 2006 and what we
found is that if your prot the
emergencies that you were typically how
a per clock cycle like you know per
thousand clock cycles using a very
aggressive margin just purely for
characterization purposes then you see
that in some benchmarks the noise is
very flat right whereas in some cases
you end up with some kind of phase you
know a minor minor a minor voltage noise
swing in some extreme cases you get a
large number of a very large amount of
variance and that variance basically
happens because of the micro
architectural stalls we've actually been
able to correlate all of this noise down
to the micro architectural activity
and so the question is how can we
actually use that intelligently you can
actually pair multiple threads with very
different behavior together and you'll
get a large amount of variance so don't
approve that what I'm showing you here
is I take one benchmark that's here and
combined it with every other benchmark
on the x-axis and then I show the
distribution that we see in terms of how
much voltage how many voltage
emergencies we get right and that's what
the box plot is effectively showing you
and the blue point is a pretty good
comparison point because it's basically
saying what happens if I just run a
program with itself gives us some kind
of comparison point and what we see is
that there's a huge amount of variance
so in most cases you know it's it's
almost a hundred Emergencies difference
right then this is per clock per
thousand clock cycles yeah that's just
because we're using a very aggressive
setting to trying to determine how to
you know what the noise characteristics
are but there's a huge amount of
variance and so what you can actually do
is you can actually schedule the code
and tell scheduled threads on you know
using the OS or hypervisor across the
cores intelligently will be possible
when you've got kind of an efficient
operating system that's coordinated
possible
I'm sorry if you've got a message
passing based thing where each ports
operating independently other and you
can do a coordination
so I haven't actually looked at it when
you have that that kind of mechanism but
maybe at that point it would be it would
it would open up the door or wall can
you actually look at the interactions
between the threads right because that's
very different from the case we're
looking at here where the threads or the
programs are completely independent
right but in that case there might be
interactions and one of the things I was
doing on the chip was to actually see if
you can what happens if one if you have
a producer/consumer relationship and you
release something and then there's a
certain burst or factory on the second
core then we find that it's pretty I've
had a tough time trying to really be
able to take a picture for instance on a
scope because it's really a whole bunch
of activity that ends up starting up
it's not just a few instructions but I
think that there might be something we
would be able to do just looking at the
traffic that's coming in and out of
threads especially if it each one is
just bound to a single core
so there's been a lot of work in in in
the space basically in terms of
scheduling threats right typically we've
been looking at scheduling threads in
the operating system community for
voltage noise sorry for performance
reasons right
and typically what you're trying to do
is you're trying to minimize the
bottleneck you have at the shared
resource the cache and so that gets rid
of one percent you know by optimizing
for cache sharing your an effect
removing the cache stalls in a way and
if you remove the bottle and cache
stalls that means you would expect that
okay some of Mailand the noise has to go
down because you just got rid of some of
the stalls but turns out that that alone
is not is not enough because you do have
to account for other kinds of events
that are happening inside the processor
like I said there's branches as TLB and
there's a lot of interaction which I
haven't shown here in the slides but all
those interactions create the different
levels of noise swings in the to prove
that point what I'm showing you here is
I'm looking at you know so x axis is IPC
so let's say you know if I schedule
intelligently for IPC only based on
hardware metrics which is you know a
pretty well-established literature space
out there I'm showing you that if you
schedule five PC you're gonna get better
performance relative some driver to some
baseline here we're just spec rate in my
case right but the problem is you end up
with more groups because your system is
completely agnostic of what is going on
underneath underneath the schedule
itself and when once I actually tag on
the recovery cost the performance
actually decreases dramatically it can
even go into the negative space right
but if you already intelligently
schedule for drupes alone you're trying
to say like I just want to pair threads
based on some activity history
I want to pair threads that are actually
causing lower number of recoveries then
you can see that the put you end up with
a little bit of performance win but
that's really not the point that's just
you know an artifact ibly but the
biggest point is that the number of
droops you see relative to your baseline
decreases and that's a good thing
because that means now you have for your
recoveries effectively and so it makes
this very strong case that scheduling
for
is very different than scheduling for
performance okay and I'm showing you
what happens when you have random just
random schedules if you're not you know
if you're not scheduling for performance
or anything you're just carrying threads
together do you get to get the job done
which is pretty much what the Linux
scheduler if you look at it really turns
out to be doing it's it's not truly
random but the effect is effectively the
same thing as random and so that's the
point I'm trying to make here is when
you're looking at multiple threads a
multiple course then there's a large
amount of room for optimization by
looking at this at the software level
because trying to build mechanisms at
the hardware level and CMP systems will
be extremely hard for this and I think
the way to think about the software
piece is the last thing I think
Venusaur forget the last thing I won't
ever want to hear is that oh the
hardware is going to be faulty so you
need to make sure your codes always
going to be correct right and you have
to do all this optimization I think that
would just never ever work but rather
the way I think about it is look we're
gonna design the hardware intelligently
as well as we can to mitigate some of
these problems because this is really
gonna start eating us in terms of energy
efficiency and stuff then the software
guys could really think about it as look
oh here's another opportunity for
performance optimization because cache
misses and branch mispredictions for
instance are just one specific thing
that we optimize for in the case that
I'm really trying to construct here is
as this becomes a big problem and you
get the right substrate at the hardware
level then you push this as an
optimization problem at the software
level so by just getting rid of the
recovery cost and you get better
performance naturally and so just to
summarize the things as you know I
covered in the talk I mentioned that
margins increasingly causing frequency
loss power efficiency and increase the
cost price of a chip and I mentioned
that by tolerating you can actually
intelligently avoid the thing right if
all of that you have to look at how the
voltage is fluctuating the time within
the processor and once you learn avoid
avoidance is important because you're
tracking the right information there
then you can actually use a software to
completely get rid of the problem itself
and so we have come up with this
three-tiered architecture basically you
know a tolerance of Borden's and
elimination that I really think is
applicable to this particular problem
but people haven't yet completely
understood yet
and the variation if you remember the
first slide that I started off you know
though this direction on this process
variations that thermal variations and
there is some this voltage variation and
we looked at the voltage variation is
happening at a very fine-grain timescale
but we might be able to extract this
into the general process you know how do
you generally handle variations as a
scheme and I think basically the
architecture built up actually works
pretty well for this thing and I think
this notion of tolerating errors is
something that we are going to be seeing
in the future the architecture will be
tolerating the errors and that's just
how we're gonna get just the way we use
so in effect you're gonna be speculating
all the time on correctness instead of
just I mean that we already do that with
branch mispredictions and or like in a
memory speculation and this is just
gonna be another notion that's already
gonna be coming out because like I said
like on Friday I'm actually gonna be
talking to the guys who have put the
chip together and they do have a
prototype chip 1/10 all right now that
does this and is actually running the
programs to completion basically so that
would be my talk any questions
our kiss girls
do you have any sense of xur's following
up on this earlier question how much the
compiler and prediction methods need to
be aware of the variation across chips
that you mentioned very early
photography especially with regards to
temperature and
process variations I think it sort of
depends on hmm I think it depends on
what your workload characteristics are
so let's say if let's let's say we talk
about process variations right and then
you know one core will obviously be
running at a much lower frequency and
you don't necessarily want to put in a
multi-threaded workload you don't want
to put the critical section on that core
for instance right there would be a lot
of benefit from moving that core into
the into the one with less or variations
because you even be able to operate a
higher clock rates and get through that
and the ones were you know if you're
just purely looking at basically
crunching through non critical sections
then you might want to be able to
schedule the threads intelligently that
way because you have cortical or process
variation subset if you schedule a here
B here you get emergencies
these schedule of the other way around
you might not actually get the
emergencies because of the tiny
variations yeah geese match up with
do these signatures like they for one
particular architecture do that they
depend a lot on the workload
see they actually depend very much on
the workload and the architecture saw it
and show it here but so this was based
on several you know I think it was about
fifty five different programs the the
experimental set I'm talking about is
fifty five unique very very unique
programs and then we looked at three
very different architectures in terms of
the aggressiveness of the configuration
and the emergency care that the patterns
you court the information we're
recording is correct but the orderings
are obviously completely different so it
has to be a very dynamic thing it's not
something you would say like okay I'm
just gonna capture this this record of
you know activity and then just do some
static compiler optimization who we
tried that that was ideally what we
wanted to be able to solve
I think our speed